welcome back guys C plus plus Library
episode two my name is Matt and we're
gonna expand things a little bit and
talk about how to continue a library
here if you haven't seen the first
episode I would highly recommend
watching it otherwise you're going to be
a little a little lost but we're going
to get into a little initial Theory here
that way if you want to scale ahead and
move on before I get to every new
episode because I'm going to cover
things carefully
um well there's some things you can do
and that's what I want to introduce this
episode with that and a bit of an
explanation for where I've been I know a
lot of you are kind of like waiting on
me to do stuff or respond or whatever
but I've been a little distracted lately
so I just haven't had much time between
working on my game and a couple other
new things
I've basically not had much time to mess
with YouTube or the community so I
apologize so if you want to support me
in my new things and me making my game
putting a lot of time in over there join
the patron supporting these videos
always helps too and uh becoming a
member on the channel always helps all
right so with that out of the way since
I don't have sponsors I feel like I
gotta gotta push that a little bit
please sign up help me out anything
helps um we're going to talk about
libraries all right so
what I like to do when I'm hypothesizing
how to do a project and structuring it
is I like to look at other projects now
this might sound obvious but it's a
pretty nice step that you can take for
free because you can just look for open
source projects on GitHub
for example we made a mention of the
Poco Library which is a networking
library for C plus plus it's open source
cross platform great open source
cross-platform Library C plus plus well
where's the source it's right on GitHub
you can just search it up just search
Poco you will find it so here it is
um and this is you know pretty battle
tested forked a lot worked on a lot Etc
it's pretty good standards here
presumably you know better than for
example you starting out you don't know
what to do
this the people here probably know what
to do for example so you can study any
of these open source libraries I'm just
using Poco here as my example but there
are tons just Google C plus plus library
and open source or something like that
you'll find all kinds of references all
over the place okay so let's take a look
at their structure they've got a bunch
of folders but you know this is the Poco
library and you're going to have
questions so here's the kind of
questions that I would ask when
organized in this Library okay so
there's there's a main Poco Library so
to speak right that's in here somewhere
um and what's all this other stuff
there's all kinds of stuff active record
Apache connector CPP parser CPP unit
crypto data etc etc all the way down to
zip and then we got build cmake contrib
more folders more folders it just seems
like a lot of stuff but most of this is
basically things we don't even need to
think about is what it comes down to we
just kind of need to get an overall
overview of what's going on here all
right so here's the overview I'm just
going to give you the over review I'm
not going to explain every little thing
because I would take forever then we got
a bunch of files all right so I guess
we'll start from the top all these files
all these not files all these folders
are just different things the project
might use at times but in this case they
have chosen to make their main source go
under Foundation you see this pretty
commonly in bigger projects with a lot
of kind of side things and little uh
these might be external libraries that
they're bringing in and stuff or just
external code that isn't necessarily
Poco related but more Universal
so the main Foundation we'll click on
Foundation we got all the Poco stuff we
got the source here's their their CPP
here's all their what they all compile
down to with poco's specific stuff for
Poco
all right there's a lot in here there's
a lot of file a lot of CP files and it
goes on and on and on
so if you wanted to clone this project
and get into a workflow you could
probably understand it a little more but
just know that you know this is
basically all the private Source all the
you know how we had an area that we said
this is the stuff we're putting here is
private end user and I will never see it
that's basically what this part is when
you're using the library of course you
can see here because it's open source
but after you build the library you
don't ever look at this again what you
look at is here in the include so I went
back uh here's the include stuff just
like we were doing same style include
and then the name well I guess we
haven't got to that we'll get to that
and this is all their public headers so
when you link this Library you're going
to need these headers to tell you what
functions are available that's all these
public headers do is they tell you what
functions are available so there should
be well nearly everything they want you
to be able to call is in these includes
so that's how they have it organized
um they've got it in a foundation so
let's back up a little bit to the top
level of Poco again so we can kind of
assume that all these other folders are
just side thing things they might be you
know CPP unit is a testing framework so
they're supporting that
um so you'll find that in a lot of
projects now I want to be careful about
how I say this but you'll find that
there's a lot of bloat and I don't mean
that in a negative way because like for
example CPP unit has nothing to do with
networking so if you clone this repo
you're getting stuff like CPP unit which
is a testing framework
um but it has nothing to do with
networking so
why am I making a point of this well you
just got to be careful because you can
accidentally overload your project and
it just becomes more confusing
unnecessarily I don't think they've done
that here necessarily but I'm just
making the point of there is a lot of
code in here that really has nothing to
do with what the actual project is it's
just various little support they want to
support unit testing for people that are
building on it all right that's actually
great you know there's nothing wrong
with that but from an end user's
perspective if you literally just want
to use the network features and you
don't want to be like working on this
Library you have no use for a lot of
this stuff potentially so just keep that
in mind because these mongodb these
appear to just be basically side
resources things are required to compile
their library but uh
you know the main foundation's still
here so can kind of consider all these
other folders as just various other
requirements now some of the end keep in
mind that some of them just aren't
required they're just here just because
it's a GitHub repo and a bunch of people
touch it and want to documented stuff so
they got docs you know you'll probably
want to look at those
um
to figure out exactly how to use this of
course and maybe you'll do the same
thing for your library at some point
you'll make some kind of Doc setup and
there's a lot of different ways of doing
that maybe we'll get to that eventually
all right well let's let's move on a
little bit yeah they've they've got
their build folder in here now I find a
lot of this to be a little weird but
they've got configs that they want to
have saved for certain situations so a
lot of really wide support here are very
very
robust Library will say so it's probably
going to be a lot bigger than what most
of us are going to solo work on but if
you contribute to stuff like this you'll
want to kind of understand what's going
on what you can mess with and why it's
here so this is a great place to kind of
dig in look at things specifically ask
questions and uh and learn more it's
it's almost a free University in a way
and chances are you can ask a lot of
these developers stuff that you get
stuck on and they might help you I have
no guarantee of that a lot of them
probably don't have time but a lot of
them also you know they're that's what
they're doing they're basically on here
to help people that's why they work on
open source a lot of times so don't be
too afraid be kind be cool all right
let's move on to these files the
non-folder files now they've got a wide
variety of build command stuff to read
me a make file and a cmakelist.text so
they're supporting cmake they're
supporting just raw make as well
probably for Linux stuff let's take a
quick look sigwin and being GW so that
would be windows
um right there but cross platform
shells there
and uh you know just uh just a basic
make file they've got some interesting
logic in here no need to really go over
the whole thing but the point is they're
supporting multiple build systems in
here so this is bigger than it normally
is like for our project we're working on
we're literally just C make own because
that's going to handle everything and uh
you know it'll work on Linux it'll work
on Mac it'll work on Windows uh you
should pretty be pretty easily be able
to convert it across any other new
platform you want but they've just got a
lot of old support here I think this
library has been around so long that
they probably got stuff that maybe is
not used much but there's probably just
a few people out there still using some
of this old stuff so you know there's
stuff like that okay environment.bat
that's for Windows environment.sh that's
going to be for Linux slash Max so
they've kind of got multi-support
multiple files for just building now of
course you want to read the instructions
for exactly uh what they expect you to
do to build this and that's what I would
do but generally something like run
configure or you run I don't know
you just check the readme I would say in
general but basically they're going to
tell you to run specific commands and
these commands are basically that's
pretty straightforward they're usually
just the boiled plate the stuff you
would type in your console but you'll
never remember because
um it's a it's it's a lot of little
jargon like what was that exact command
again it was this build win 150 build
shared both when you know this whole
array of stuff you're never going to
remember that that's why they save them
in files and just run the file
um rather than you know so that's that's
a thing
um these a lot of this stuff is somewhat
optional so I know this has been a
little bit of a broad example but I just
want to give you like a very
wide perspective here to know that it's
not always the same you kind of kind of
understand a lot of different things
that people tend to do with libraries
all right so where does that leave us
um oh I want to look at one other thing
where do they do their testing so let's
go to the top level do they have a test
folder no no tests folder so I think
there are individual tests are in each
of these so let's check Foundation Poco
okay they've got a test Suite let's see
what do they do with their test Suite
they've got source and data they've got
make files they've got Visual Studio
project stuff and they've got some a few
other things all right so what are they
actually doing here I would guess that
they're probably using CPP unit
somewhere since they've got it elsewhere
but you know really I'd have to like dig
in and see what they're doing to even
know
let's see if cmake even says exactly
because we should see it linked to
whatever they're uh they're using okay
here we go so we got a Target link
libraries they link it to the Poco
foundation and CPP unit so these yeah
their test Suite here is just using CPP
unit I tend to use native unit tests or
just c-test but there's a lot of
different test Suites out there there's
of course CPP like they're using here
you could kind of copy what they're
doing here and go go with that workflow
or you could use something else there's
also Google tests catch two I've used a
lot of them they're all approximately
the same I would say use whatever one
you find most user friendly and uh don't
worry about it too much because
generally they all do the same thing
they tested your results were what you
said they were it's a very
straightforward kind of Boolean logic to
make a test Suite when you think about
it
um but we're not gonna get digging any
further here so we want to think about
where does that leave us with our
library how do we want to organize ours
that's where you want to be when you
make your library I like the idea of
having a foundation because currently we
just have everything on the top level
we've got a dot h and Dot CBB they're
both top level it's pretty lazy the dot
h is in theory public but we haven't
really made that specific
nutrition.cvp is private but we really
haven't made that specific either so I
think all we're going to do really is
just do a little folder structure
reorganizing so
um we're we're going to go with this
Foundation setup I really kind of like
that you know that because projects tend
to have a lot of sub-projects so they're
usually and they're usually based around
a main one that the project is like Poco
had its foundation then it had all the
supporting stuff so let's do the same
thing
um and keep in mind that this is not how
everybody does it I just you know that's
what we're going with for this example
so Foundation let's go make another
couple folders here you can make folders
however if you want I'm going to make
Source I'm also going to make uh include
and we'll put this dot h in the include
we'll put this dot CBP in the source now
sometimes you see this you see even more
subfolders of like public and private
and stuff you see that with unreal a lot
I believe they do their stuff like that
but we're not going to do that here
we're kind of sticking to a more open
source and if we want to get any more
examples of how
um to kind of mirror their setup we can
do that we want a subfolder and include
with the same name looks like they've
chose to capitalize it which I totally
disagree with because the project name
is lowercase and that would throw me off
but whatever
that's uh that's fine so let's let's go
ahead and do that let's do the same
things add a folder let's add uh
nutrition
here and we'll put that dot h in it now
keep in mind we got to update our cmags
too now if you look at this they've got
a sub c make here that probably tells
all this how to build
um so we should probably do that and
they've once again got another external
live in here so you know a lot of little
external lives thrown around in here to
support what they're doing because you
know you'll see a lot of people out
there these days are like you must build
everything from the ground up from
scratch and there's definitely some
Merit to that I would agree but also you
don't want to spend your entire time
developing your network library
rewriting a test framework for example
so that's why you bring in other
libraries is basically
think of them as like a co-worker or
something you know they'll generally get
stuff done but also you got to be wary
because you know my other libraries are
not perfect
um because they're made by people and
people make mistakes and if they were
made by AI they'd be even worse but I
don't want to get into that rant so uh
they've got samples Source I like the
idea of samples I like the idea of test
Suite I think I'm just going to stick
with tests and not test Suite even
though test Suite sounds cool so we're
gonna put this test into Foundation as
well
and uh what else do we need we could
have samples now samples usually don't
actually build usually this is just
examples of how to use the library but
they actually have their samples
building currently our samples are
basically our tests because we have you
know tests that's an executable so we
can run it but they've kind of got that
separate here they've got their samples
and they've got their tests so we're
going to skip over samples for now I
think we might do that in the next
episode but I don't want to make this
too awful long on you guys so we're
going to kind of just wrap this up with
this restructure and this overview of
the project and how you need to think or
how you should generally think about
structuring it and where to find
examples I think that's basically going
to be enough so basically what we need
to do now since we've moved a bunch of
files around we need to set up our cmake
to uh reflect this and that's all we're
going to do for the rest of this episode
all right so first of all we're going to
make a new cmake and foundation
cmakelits.txt and that's going to kind
of sub handle a few things I still do
want to we gotta you gotta enable
testing on the top level so that that's
not going to change but we can add this
subdirectory from the sub level now and
uh we'll put this one as just Foundation
so the top level one is going to add the
subdirectory of foundation which will go
to this C make and this one will add
test so we want to add at least some
basic stuff here let's put our minimum
version up here
um
3.18 is what it defaulted to so whatever
we're going to take this add library and
put it in that subdirectory too our top
level one is the longer doing it
and we'll put tests down here
we're going to have to correct a few
little pathen issues we'll sort that out
let's just go back to our top one level
one make sure it's all good version
project enable testing add subdirectory
there we go looks good there's some
random comments in here I'm just gonna
delete them for now
because I don't think they're all that
relevant
all right and this one this one looks
mostly fine it just doesn't exactly have
the library pathing right so we just
need to set that up so we know that this
is in Source slash include now if we go
look at Poco let's see what they're
doing let's look at their Source let's
see if they've got yet another cmake in
here it looks like they don't
but sometimes you'll see it subdirectory
down even further you just need to look
but yeah my preference would be not to
but let's also look at these includes
and see if they've got any other just
specific things we might need to know
about let's give it a broad overview it
doesn't look like they're really doing
anything very
very specific but let's look at the
cmake list one more time and let's find
where they're doing ad Library there it
is so they're adding two different
libraries they're adding a foundation
with the sources and then they're doing
another one but they're aliasing it to
the foundation I'm not super familiar
with this but basically I think what it
does is it says hey this library is this
Library why are they doing that beats me
it's just redundant seems like redundant
code they probably have a reason though
so uh We're Not Gonna bash it I'm just
gonna say you know that's something I
don't really quite understand why
they're doing it but I'm sure they have
their reasons all right here's where
they add all their sources looks like
they got some if else depending on
specific cases of how you're building
which is fine
and they're just
setting up some stuff here
so let's find sources here and see what
they're setting that as okay it's just
this
we need to find it at the top somewhere
here yeah we gotta so we got a list of
pinned that is uh constantly appending
to the source depending on what they're
doing they got a glob at the top uh
getting all the CPP they got another
glob getting all the dot H's so that's
interesting that they're using some glob
stuff uh you often hear don't use glob
so it's interesting to see that here but
that's fine yeah that's kind of what
we're doing too just because we're being
a little lazy so we could do this whole
file thing as well and maybe we'll do
that later
and but basically all they do is they
grab all files of that type and add them
so maybe we'll go ahead and do that so
let's go file this kind of makes a
little future proof you just got to make
sure you refresh your cmake uh do we
copy their terminology that's something
we got to decide actually we're doing
like exactly this so I don't know what
sword I don't know what this G stands
for Global source is G I don't know
uh I would
I'm going to call it P for privates
um you know maybe they've got a reason
for the G I don't know what it is to me
personally P makes more sense for
private because I don't know what
they're doing um
and they've got some other stuff going
Poco sources Auto so they've got some
cmake uh files imported here that's kind
of a deep cmake thing but they've
probably got them in here yeah
they've probably got some functions or
something somewhere that they're calling
I don't know exactly where those are
going to be but just kind of keep that
in mind that you'll see special stuff
and you don't necessarily need to fully
understand it but it'd be nice to find
where this is I could probably dig in
and find it basically it sounds like
it's just appends to this sources and
that's probably what this is doing too I
don't know
we're not going to worry about that too
much we're just going to kind of hard
code it in quickly
let's do a recurse on this one oh what
am I doing
um don't need double glob so glob
recurse goes down through all the file
structures I'm not even gonna put these
P and H on there we're just not going
into that sort of detail in this project
so
we want to go into the include and then
start.h and now because it is recurse it
should also look down into this
subfolder we just need to make sure we
reference these so instead of hard
coding them here on this ad Library
we're going to end up doing basically
both of these to call these variables
and get everything out of them you gotta
surround it with the curly braces
I guess I'll zoom in better late than
never and uh same thing here the headers
so now we should be adding our library
correctly should be adding a test
correctly and if everything went to plan
we're good I think we need to do an ADD
subdirectory
no we should be good let's just generate
and see if this works
I didn't see any errors didn't see any
on error list let's go to our test
Explorer see if that's Happy uh it is
it was
okay so what we can do if we want to
build these individually is just switch
this to the solution other solution view
go to cmake targets check out our
targets here we got our library and we
got our tester let's go ahead and just
build this Library I cannot include file
okay so uh yeah this is kind of
important to know
now obviously we put our header in CPP
files in different folders pretty vastly
different but they do need to know about
each other like this one still wants to
know this header so you can like hard
path to it you can go you know back a
directory not only to include now into
nutrition and now into the actual header
there so that'll fix it but if you don't
want to do all this like in this Library
you know we always want access to this
include so we can just put that in our
cmake below the ad library with Target
include directories
and the target is this guy here we want
public their public libraries and we
just need the path so if we're in a
cmake project we'll go cmake Rooter well
I think it's actually sorcerer I always
forget this one
and that is going to give you the path
to basically your top level cmake is
going to give you the folder that your
top level cmake is in so no matter what
one you're in it's going to get you that
top level right there so we know from
the top level we then go into Foundation
we don't want to type of those we can
just copy these folder names
no risk with typo when you copy pasta
include
and then all the way down you don't
necessarily have to go all the way down
but we are in this case and now I'm
going to surround this by double quotes
I'm not entirely sure if you need to do
that it seems to seem to have mixed
results on that so
let's see if this now compiles because
now if we go back to here we shouldn't
need this path because it has it in its
include directories now all right so
let's go back to our solution here and
just go to our targets View and see if
we can go ahead and build our main
library and just right click and do that
again looks like it builds let's build
our tester build
it can't open a directory okay so same
thing with our tester
let's address that we'll get this
compiling here
so our tester also wants to find this
header so we can do a similar thing well
we can also just path to it like we did
originally or we could take this little
C make and do the same thing uh as this
one take these clue directories
put it in there
anywhere after the ad executable is fine
let's put it down let's put it right
here it seems like a good order make
sure you get the right name since we do
a copy paste and there we go we go right
to it so it might be the case that you
only want to go in your test to include
and that's fine that just means you have
to make sure preface systems with the
folder you left out up to you how you do
that
um a lot of people like leaving the
folder in front because it makes a
little more clarity as to what library
you're bringing in for example there's a
lot of common file names that come up
for example a lot of libraries end up
having a file called bitset.h so if you
want to know where you're getting your
bits at dot h for example uh keeping the
folder in front is nice because there's
a gazillion bitset.h's out there just an
example but we've got it simple enough
that it's just a single file so we're
just going to go all the way to it but
just wanted to make you aware that
that's a thing let's put I don't know if
you need the trailing slash at all right
there I don't think you do but it seems
to work fine either way okay so let's go
to our test Explorer hit play our tests
still aren't filled out completely
we not save this file
oh I corrected the path we got to
correct that again okay now we should
see some tests if everything goes well
oh we're still getting some kind of
error I think we just need to force a
rebuild here no work on the library it's
build the tests test succeeds okay and
there we go we got our uh we got our
little test going on so the test is
working it's re-linking we got it
restructured so I hope you've enjoyed
this episode about uh you know I think
this is this is kind of a nice step I
think just kind of understanding some
structure stuff so that you can continue
on but once you got it structured how
you want basically you know you you do
what you want you keep adding to your
program keep adding to your library and
we'll talk about more later now I didn't
really have any comments from the last
video that were relevant to libraries
and stuff so I'm not really sure what
questions to answer but please let me
know if you have any or if anything's
confusing I'll try to wrap those up in
future episodes so that this works as
kind of a complete YouTube University
type course all right well that's all I
got for this one hope you've enjoyed if
you got a lot out of this consider
supporting the channel it would mean a
lot for me continuing these in the
future and I'll see you guys in the next
one peace